hey everyone thor ragnarok is now in
theaters worldwide and we are here with
our reactions why our favorite scenes
and moments work so well and how the
director and cast and writers made thro
ragnaroks such a success yay
now this is the need to know it's a
weekly deep dive into all of the biggest
news this week so we're also gonna talk
about that new Star Wars the last Jedi
trailer that came out specifically a few
visual details that you might have
missed also we're gonna dig into the
music for the new Justice League movie
plot details for the upcoming Avengers
infinity war han solo movie Logan and
more now all these stories are based on
the requests and reactions that you guys
sent us via Stardust check our star dust
download link in the description below
so that you can upload your reactions to
your favorite movies and TV shows tag us
at new rock stars and yeah and get them
featured on this show I've been talking
a lot by the way hey I'm Erik Bosse your
host and the rest of these beautiful
idiots joining me at this table or
basher here at Sam bash on Twitter Phil
Molina
Tommy Bechtold got my nice Texas tan I'm
not from the future my advice would be
don't eat a lot of dominos mod if you
can hear this also we're very proud of
you and we stand with you thank you yeah
Maude Garrett obviously is not with this
was this week where's Gigi out of town
well let's get started with our top
story yeah thor ragnarok we have all
seen it and we're gonna talk about what
we loved about it some specific details
why we loved it but first here is a
little reaction from Maggie on Stardust
just got back from seeing thor ragnarok
and oh my goodness it was a grand ol
time I'm really happy with how this
movie turned out it's such a shift from
Thor's previous movies and I loved it
I think it's a great addition to this
direction that the MCU is going in and I
think it's all leading up to something
that's gonna be so spectacular and so
amazing and shout out to Sam basher for
his video on new rock stars because I
definitely got the
for a joke ah Thank You Maggie yeah I
totally agree movie was amazing
it's my mom's name but that wasn't my
mom raagh throg becktall miss strawberry
Rochester New York 1964 through 69 are
you don't talk about my mom that way
well a heads up for you guys we may
touch on some plot points from the movie
it's probably safe to say that this will
be a spoiler review but we will warn you
before we discuss any of the big stuff
from the ending of the movie so don't
worry about that
so um what did you guys think what were
these standout moments for you
personally I loved how funny this movie
was it's about like the funniest easily
in the MCU that's what this movie's
trying to be it's trying to be the phil
lord chris miller kind of movie it felt
like you belong to me no universe you
know you know this - you break down -
like the amount of references that
they're jamming in as jokes and like
interpreting those in a funny way like
coreg obviously it was just like a
little Corgi in there and let's make him
just like charming and sweet and and
that's so it he is the highlight for me
him and me car pretty Mika I was I saw
with my friend DJ and he's like I just
want the action figure for Mika a little
knife and so many things that you almost
want to watch it again to watch the
jokes that are happening in the
background
there's one that happens with him where
cord comes in he's like where do you
fire and then like he comes in like even
later like he goes like yeah I thought I
you know along with being Phil Lord and
Chris Miller s it was also like the the
interaction the interpersonal
interactions were very what we do in the
shadows is incredibly uncomfortable and
like even just the reactions of people
were so organic and like not necessarily
grandiose like you would get in a normal
superhero or big blockbuster movie they
were much like smaller and more human
oddly enough right
about demigods and aliens it's like
uncomfortably comfortable kind yeah it's
just like because we've all like had
these like weird things we're like just
stop talking no one starts talking
through one moment where they all just
kind of like Cork felt like Teddy he's
like the guy that always knows chords
like he's the guy like he he'll come
over and help me fix your stuff but like
oh so we don't know we're supposed to
run into our barbecue or not like he's
kind of weird but you know can can we
talk about the like force of nature
though that was Jeff Goldblum's
performance oh my god he was like a Brit
to me he like embodied what the whole
like point of this movie was he's just
kind of like detached and just fun and
colorful and this work like his skin
color had changed I feel like it's like
covered him in like oompa loompa makeup
yeah I didn't realize he had that kind
of tan but like man just like he was
just kind of like looking around and
just reacting to how weird and and
comic-book he everything was in this
really fun way and I felt like this is
you can just look at Jeff Goldblum and
be like this is the kind of movie this
is when he does not address Thor or
anyone by their real names I'm like
that's good must be how he is in real
life
yeah I was half hears things he's like
oh they say he goes back to like typing
stuff he was like an 11 out of 10 on the
Goldblum like quirks down like he was
like kind of like weirdly like fluidly
sexual with everyone and I also just not
connected to anyone and he also had like
the great like I kind of like prick boss
vibe about I was like I'm gonna keep
smiling and acting like everything's
great but really like I don't like any
of you what we saying ahead of time that
it seemed like no one had given no they
had a cute card it's like just say
store and here see you can make like a
joke about this like a weird name I
think they like he wasn't even supposed
to be in the movie he was like walking
on costume yeah just say what you would
say in real life
merely that's not a that's not the
costume department he had that so it all
up he's like I also love to play piano
they're like great we'll give you a
space Polygram that displaces the whole
the arena that like keeps his quarks
like it's not like usually if you see
like a big kind of like Zordon as thing
it's like find him like so maybe they're
out there and they're like look at
something agreed I I'd every other
character they introduced was amazing I
really liked and I want to say a new
character is hope because he actually
has any personality wherever and you
felt for him a lot which was really cool
and there's some I'm glad this movie did
have some emotional beats where instead
of it's not just jokes like 100 miles an
hour at your favorite constantly there
are emotional beats and you get to learn
more about Thor and when in like with
the first Thor movie they're like we'll
take away his hammer that weighs more
human yes to be with humans and this he
actually felt human and he felt more
like a god because usually he feels like
he's this weird space alien that can
pick up this giant hammer and this he's
like no he's like oh God
he is a fundamental piece of the
universe that raid earth or Asgard or
whatever you want to call it yeah I
almost have a pitch for like a Superman
movie based on what they did here where
it's Superman it's always so hard to
find anyone that can fight Superman in a
movie especially because like the
effects are never able to to like live
up to what we need all right so it's
it's hard to challenge him so it'd be
really cool to put Superman back on
Krypton and there he has to save the day
and it's like well there you just
average that's very much what Thor felt
like throw it's an entire movie I mean
he's not even the best fighter of the
Asgardians that's with them like that
you know like both both hella but also
the Valkyrie we find out like she is
able to probably kick his ass and she
does actually
so just Thor as a normal every man which
you with those arms but otherwise normal
every man
is actually a new place to take yeah it
felt like this is for both Thor and Hulk
this is like exactly where you would
want to put these characters in these
scenarios to really like bring out the
truest aspects of them like I love that
Bruce Banner was in the most stimulating
world imaginable I loved the whole like
the getting hit in the face with the
green dust and which if you look closely
is like I feel like throughout the movie
there's still like elements with the
blue but yeah I in both cases like we
get to see them in their most truest
form I think and this is exactly what I
would want to see as much as I'd like
seeing Thor trying to be a fish out of
water on earth it was fun just to put
him in an even more absurd crazy reality
and seeing him have to fight with his
hands because I feel like that is who
Thor is at his core like he's desperate
to fight in these kind of movie to me
felt like of all of the Thor and
Avengers movies that included Loki
people that's not to do tap my fingers
on the table situate my points I felt
like this was the most like nuanced yet
perfect use of Loki in these movies like
it wasn't like he didn't like ruin
things are ethically or
he didn't make it so irredeemable what
he did and also he dressed like Tommy
was so for the first 20 minutes
everybody really did look exactly like
he had the black on black suit with the
Tommy was so kind of like scraggly hair
I do not impersonate him not I did not
become Odin I didn't do it no Highmark
yeah I think this movie there's a
certain point where I feel like you get
a little nervous of like oh man did they
did they water down Loki or do they make
him like a safe comical trickster see
the Kramer almost remind ya god of
thunder he's got a mischief right is
supposed to be that thing we're just
like like I'm wild card by Nature I
designed a wild card I am the element of
wild card and being mischievous yeah I
really liked it also this movie felt
more than other comic
movies it felt like a a trade of a comic
because it's like here's the intro of
like this is where the story's gonna be
in the you get like everything talking
about Odin then you get like well now
here's the New York part in like that's
when Doctor Strange gets a jump in here
and that feels like oh it's a guest
issue to try to get more people but it's
like it doesn't pertain it all to what's
happening elsewhere but it but as the
movie goes on you're like yeah I can see
is like they took to trade two trades of
comics and they put it they made a movie
out of it which is not bad I love the
way this movie played out and even
though it Doctor Strange felt like the
most out of place out of everything I
loved it I really liked seeing him it
was an event it wasn't a bad business
move to remind people cuz Doctor Strange
was definitely the most like out there
Marvel like solo movie and I felt like
okay this is a good reminder of like now
he's be actually become the sorcerer
supreme and like he's really good at
doing this stuff now I don't know how
spoiler he we can get this isn't about
the ending but uh the the big rumor like
leading up to the movie like a year ago
was that address Elvis character was
gonna die and instead everyone else just
died Ray Stevenson didn't even get a
line in the movie he put the sword into
the Bifrost and then just took two to
the ribs and then was the other guy the
guy who plays like the like Robin Hood I
do have some gripes with the movie and I
think yeah we're gonna get two when we
get couple absolutely I think that was
supposed to everyone I think was
supposed to recognize hey our beloved
character oh yeah oh man and I don't
think we know oh I also didn't think
that they were that beloved either no I
do I mean I didn't I didn't really care
too much
also Zachary Levite was the second guy
to play that I know yeah he wasn't and
then he was again yeah I liked
like the characters that show up on
agents of shield level of like families
like oh yeah that'd be a big deal on the
TV show but like it's a Thor movie and I
get like SIF was like Jamie Alexander
was like yeah they call me like last
minute to like come on set so I couldn't
do it because of blind spot I'm like oh
I get it because this scene feels very
tacked on they're like we should maybe
throw them in there and I do like that
the guy who had like the final stand a
little bit with hella who could kind of
hold his own I'm sorry I don't remember
his character's name I was got it was
him at the very least it was Moody oh is
that Karl Urban no no no because there
is like the warrior 3 or the warrior 4
with the mace
yeah the mace guy basically see I don't
know we don't know their names obviously
because we love them some yeah these are
existing characters from the franchise
yeah but they're not really yeah yeah
and actually I think it now's a good
time to talk about maybe some of the
thoughts we had on the ending or later
in the movie but if you still haven't
seen the movie and you want to skip that
we're putting in a skip time somewhere
in here yeah right there it is I just
get to that time and then we'll talk to
us and skip skip around your apartment
house you know what yeah it gets the
blood flowing it makes you just happy
but yeah let's talk about the ending of
this movie it was one of the things that
I appreciated the most about the way
tiger would teeth you went forward with
this story last time we're talking about
Hulk I talked about how he wanted to
embrace the idea of the the ragnerok
spirit and just like charge full forward
at the end of the world and I'd love how
like the the twist at the end of this
was that you know they were afraid of
the into the world happening of trying
to put new they wanted to prevent
Ragnarok and then the decision was like
no let's just like let nature take its
course and just have fun on the way down
and adapt to that change and it kind of
had this feeling to me like the end was
in the beginning you know at the very
beginning the movie searcher makes that
promise Thor says oh that would be a
spectacle to see and then at the movie
that we see that spectacle and it's
amazing to see reminded me of like cabin
in the woods or this is the end and just
like kind of delighting and seeing the
world in it was almost funny in a way
and like I think that's one of the
things that just made this movie so
charming is that it wasn't trying to
just go through those motions of
stopping the end of the world and
hitting pause on the ticking time-bomb
at two seconds you know
the spectacle of it I think emotionally
it wasn't the end of Asgard as it should
have felt like because it had that
syndrome that a lot of movies do when
you destroy a planet where it's a good
thing there's only a thousand people on
this planet you know make sure what you
see they're like all right we've saved
the Asgardians and it's like on one ship
that's like not bigger than the Titanic
right yeah I can't really tell because
when they keep calling as guard to plan
it I'm like this looks like one really
big like a big city but still it looks
like a resort just looks like Atlantis
and NASA like this a waterslide you can
swim with sharks if you want also all of
the military personnel in NASCAR has
been murdered like really only civilian
safety I will say it was the opening
scene was the coolest Thor scene ever
with surgery
coolest coolest fight is amazing yeah
I'm coming it back around seeing search
here again as the reason that it all
dies and also we realize that we've seen
the death of Asgard since the very first
trailer for this movie which is a bit of
a bummer I don't know I don't know why I
got I got kind of bummed I'm like oh it
sucks that I already saw this even
though I'm not even gonna be a dream
sequence it was gonna happen earlier or
something like that say the reason maybe
it sucked is because I had a similar
feeling even though I really really
enjoyed seeing it right when they're
putting that plan together he's like
wait we'll make it happen right at that
moment trailer image shows of my head of
my own so we're gonna see I'm Cheyenne
yeah so just like it keeps you in the
notes like right before you see it
mm-hmm I did but having banner jump out
of the ship and just it was so well shot
because like Fenrir the wolf just like
same thing and I also forgot like no you
can't die there's not there's there's
literally no way that banner can ever
die do you lead though he didn't believe
it he bled which is a pretty big deal
actually a lot of people even wonder
can't hopefully right yeah but no like I
think in the first Avengers they brought
up that one deleted scene where like
bannered tried to shoot himself in the
mouth but hope he hoped out before it
could happen the bullet was so it's like
no there's an of course he's not gonna
die from this little thing of course but
it was I think that might be the point I
laughed the hardest in the movie and
having a whole fight searcher because he
can't understand what's happening
I really enjoyed any I loved the finale
he got the cool like exit line like now
you'll see who I really yeah
[Laughter]
did we have any other things that maybe
didn't pay off for us let's get into
some maybe some minor gripes that we
might have had things that they could
have done better
minor gripes I at times we were talking
about this before but there there are
times when it kind of feels like there
are two movies maybe yeah maybe even
three movies where they are happening
here and it feels like taiko TT had the
most fun making the Planet Hulk movie
Thor cuz hoax already there he's just
and then there's hella and it's just
like we were talking about like it would
it would have been cool if more [ __ ]
happened for either of the stories like
if it had another beat and then they
came together because then it makes it
seem like Oh Thor grew more or like Hulk
and Thor are clearly friends and we can
see that a little bit more or hellas
like actually a real threat like she
took out a whole army amazing but she ya
didn't she sat down and like I don't
know because the movies not short no but
it does feel specifically like they're
missing one sequence in like of a battle
on Sekar submit that or maybe Thor
getting his ass beat and like kind of
being spit on kinda like a gladiator
kind of journey for him and him having
to like rise back up and lead everyone
or whatever you kind of felt like it was
about something of that scale is gonna
happen and it doesn't and then with the
hella story also you kind of feel like
okay she kills all of the the Asgardian
warriors and then you're like and then
what's she gonna do oh nothing she
breaks her paintings yeah
sealing I think like just this is gonna
sound like I'm contradicting a
compliment earlier but like this movie
to me could have been called as
guardians of the galaxy because thick
like colors and jokes fell very
guardians of the galaxy influence to me
like in a good way and I think like
certainly the director whose name I
always butcher Taiki Tycho what's Hika
what tiny white that tiny tiny white but
I think like they're like I I took you
all to remember like oh he's also a
brilliant comedy dresser because at
first I was like this is just like
guardians of the galaxy even with the
synth which is done by Mark Mothersbaugh
from Devo and is great but like that is
used so heavily in the Guardians movie
those like funky symphonies more and
then so I thought that like I loved
thorn
I thought this was a great movie I had a
great time but I couldn't help but feel
like they were pressured into making it
slightly goofier than it may be needed
to be I don't for me that's always gonna
play funnier but for more like serious
comic fans I could see them being
annoyed by how light-hearted a lot of
the moments or maybe not even annoyed
but just like it's it's a different
journey than you expect I'll say the
first part I think it's a different kind
of funny than guardians personally I
think they are similar but this does
feel like a little bit of the Kiwi humor
which is a little more uncomfortable
sure I kind of joking and and improv
based but at the second part I
definitely see where it's like I I love
comedy I love funny movies and I really
feel like you have to have comedy or
funny in anything that's dramatic in
order for me to actually believe it's
real because if it's pure drama I'm
actually gonna disconnect I'm like well
these characters aren't real right
because in real life even when I'm sad I
joke around a little bit yeah so I need
that but in this movie I'll say it
actually probably was almost only that
to the extent I had the same issue with
Lego Batman actually which is another
very very funny movie in a movie I write
very high and I think it's great to go
watch and you don't care at all about
the characters actually achieving their
goals and your
mostly not worried that they won't
achieve their goals because it starts to
feel like a cartoon that will
essentially get everyone's gonna be fine
and it's gonna happen and it doesn't
feel like the stakes are real and I
think that's why we didn't really care
when the major deaths happened when
hello shows up and it's like okay like
there was some emotion when because
we're in spoiler like a few things right
we're in spoilers we sure yeah yeah Odin
dies you're like like it doesn't like it
just like we found him and it less than
three minutes away like after that he's
gone and then but like right where did
he go like I thought if he's a Asgardian
you have to die in back horse yeah you
know there'll be a bunch of Anthony
Hopkins all over the world and then get
paid off with at the end when like
Thor's losses I and he can like actually
talk to his father about like what the
hammer means and what it's like to have
your depth of field change you know I
mean that's why hammers are not a great
idea now because you probably couldn't
make a real dumb question I hate
literally I can't believe I don't even
want to admit this I just like blinked
too hard right at that moment I was like
where does I beat up those blinky got a
little knife in the corner just flicked
it right out yeah she's very casual you
were day that's all the promo art for
Avengers infinity war it has him with
both peepers and yeah I think my only
gripe with the movie was like Senator
Riley action I agree with you guys I
think my I love the whole gladiator
fight between Hulk and Thor and I think
this was the one action sequence maybe
other than the opening with the like
dragon in the hammer where they were
able to like work the comedy into the
action and they were like when you watch
a really good Jackie Chan fight sequence
he's like really funny he's like got
great timing you know it's I don't like
set things up and pay them off and like
some of the better Marvel movies that
like
when you think like the Avengers or or
some of the Iron Man movies they did a
good job like working the comedy into
the action like he had good dialogue I
think Iron Man 3 is like a good example
like Shane black wrote that script and
he did a good job like setting up comedy
in the dialogue but also like you have
these scenes where he has different
pieces of the armor that like house
isn't like the there's like setup and
payoff and surprises in the action and I
just wish that there was a bit more of
that in the action of this movie I saw
it in the gladiator fight because yeah
that was that surprised me in a lot of
ways but like the rest of the movie I'm
just like oh yeah this is kind of a
traditional despite scene it felt like
everyone involved knew they had to have
mm-hmm but not that I actually like the
fights themselves were where they're
gonna get really creative the most
creative moment probably is the hammer
in the mouth yeah yeah well we want you
to let us know what you think actually
we're gonna check in with another
Stardust reaction this time from little
ginger ninja guys right it's amazing
it's hilarious laughing the entire time
I see Chris Hemsworth in this more
comedic role that we've been seeing of
him lately
I loved the New Zealand and Australian
Easter eggs that was in it with the Kiwi
really putting on these accent and the
ship being named after Australian car
the Commodore I think this beat
spider-man guys I love spider-man but I
think this beats it it's amazing oh yeah
yeah thanks for pointing that out that's
we'll be using that for a breakdown
probably they'll be coming out next week
but actually we wanted to give you guys
kind of a prompt here we're gonna start
doing this we want to leave you guys
with a start us question what joke and
thor ragnarok made you laugh the hardest
you know well what did he find the
funniest in the movie and like tell us
what laugh was like you know did he like
took a popcorn and people like do that
we return or just post your response as
a reaction on Stardust which remember
you can get by clicking on the download
link in description below Joe can be
like just straight-up funniest yeah
anything that you really loved we just
want to give you guys like a specific
thing that we wanted to see what all of
you guys found the funniest
see I remember to tag us at new rock
stars in that reaction and yeah next
week we might
your reaction in this video
been there twice okay how often you
would just turn and show me a gift all
right well let's move on to our weekly
trivia question the cards over here
apparently this week's is based on the
new season of stranger things okay which
is great because this week our breakdown
is gonna be coming out very soon if it's
not already out when you're watching
this and yeah because I spent all week
watching this over and over again I
haven't slept I'm very very very tired
but so let's read this question here we
go in stranger things to season two what
is the name of the character played by
body builder Kai Greene I guess that's
oh yes that is a guy in collies gang and
episode seven so what is his character's
name interesting okay and while we write
down her questions we're gonna hear from
labyrinth on start us with a question
she had about the opening scene and
stranger things season two with this
gang okay I have to ask the universe
about this this thing that bugged me for
about ten minutes on the cold open of
the whole series they made special care
and effort to show Callie wiping her
nose to reveal her number but if she
wiped her nose like this it would have
looked like eight hundred this way
because when you like get tattooed it
would have been zero eight eight why did
they do it backwards ah that is a very
interesting point labyrinth yeah so I
guess it would be eight hundred I don't
know if that's just something the
production designer wanted to have I'm
gonna have to rewatch that I need her
like rewatch episode seven because it's
a really really interesting point maybe
she wanted the viewers to see it right
you planted that okay so yeah we're
gonna have some steaks here the closest
answer as decided by our judges will do
our sign-off goodbyes at the end of the
video while it okay the loser will face
a horrible punishment that will be
revealed later which we do not know what
it actually do not know news show and
yeah I reminder that you can watch might
Ranger things full season breakdown and
check out last week's episode of the
need to know for a review of the season
with some interesting points brought up
there but let's move on to the other big
news to drop this week guys a new short
trailer for the Star Wars the Star Wars
the last Jedi a lot of footage we saw
was already in the past trailer but I
noticed a few key interesting shots that
are new but I think deserve a closer
look so we're gonna do a mini breakdown
here using my favorite breakdown segment
called
I would say wait for it but it's already
on the back screen
so okay the first shot that I want to
look closely at zoom and enhancing on is
this first shot of Luke in the cockpit
on the Millennium Falcon now obviously
it's great to see Luke return to a
familiar place and to remember how to
activate all the control panels that was
fun but check out Mark Hamill's
expression here like I I'm not sure if
that's an expression of nostalgia slash
haunted by my past or is that like I
shouldn't be in here I'm sneaking it I'm
hijacking the ship right now maybe you
can't really see his eyes you can't
check into his soul what's what do you
guys think is going on here
I think he's about to wreck it he seems
like he's a little off his rocker a
little bit in this movie honestly I
the first was such fanservice force
awakens I know people will give tear me
apart of the comments I felt like it was
such fanservice and this is more
fanservice
I kind of in my mind I'm like you know
what screw up just like I was like using
the force and just crush it and then
like he just runs away like
yeah I feel like this would be the
moment in the movie where we've just
completed training with Rey and she's
now somehow talked him into at least
going on one part of the journey with
her and she's kind of like this is his
first time being back in this space and
he's just get letting that all kind of
fill him in because he also very clearly
has tried to push that entire life out
and right you know this hermit yeah I to
me this is kind of like going back to
your old high school and he's to like
direct trophies yeah promised myself I'd
never get in a boat again but Here I am
it's kind of kind of the person inviting
you you're like I know you went through
like a war got a battleship again yeah
your friend Ivan last movie and he kind
of was on the ship a lot right before
then so Luke is well aware that there is
currently a war going like getting back
on the Falcon to go back into battle
well the next shot I want to zoom and
enhance on obviously the biggest shot I
think from the trailer is this one of
supreme leader snoke sitting on his
throne in this red Hall flanked by
Praetorian guards and you can see
general Hux in that shot I think this
the first look we get of them in the
last Jedi and we hear Snoke voiceover
saying darkness rises and lied to meet
it that's perfect Andy Serkis right but
let's actually lean back rather than
zooming in and focused on the
composition of this shot like the shape
of the red on black to me kind of makes
it look like we're looking at this room
through the shape of the helmet of Darth
Vader like notice the two red portions
kind of like the eye pieces and the
walkway that comes out like a rhombus is
that the right thing is they it's kind
of like the breathing apparatus of the
helmet I don't know maybe I'm stretching
here but do you guys if so think this
would be like intentional and or if so
like why would the director want to
evoke Darth Vader in this moment well
there's definitely I mean I actually
don't think you're wrong it immediately
makes you think of masked in the first
maybe a little bit more
like guardians and masters but at the
same time I will say that it it's
reminiscent of what we recently have for
the first time saying invaders home yeah
yeah Mustafar yeah yeah and so like
there is something that I'm getting
we're like I imagine like maybe these
are essentially glass enclosures that
are keeping out lava or some sort of
rain there's no sure yeah I I'm the most
the most exciting thing for me is
hearing the music and seeing the
different planets and whatnot in the
locations in these movies it's always so
much fun so if that is the imagery
they're going for great that's amazing
that's a makes me more excited for this
movie yeah of course this could just be
like you know us all magic I mean things
that are not there which it's kind of
our job here at new rock stars so as we
go crazy for you outfit smokes outfits
is going really I like an old decrepit
leader that loves to wear gold it just
resonates with the current yeah
the microphone I just scared me and my
face okay the next shot I want to zoom
in enhance on is this one a thin in the
cockpit of a different ship yeah baby
whoo
now obviously notice how the cockpit
dome is open I feel like we don't really
don't use it at sheer but in the
background yeah you can see the famous
red does so maybe this is on that crate
battle right that we've seen like with
the cruisers speeding toward the the
gorilla walkers but I think the fact is
Noah's open suggest that yeah we might
be in some kind of action scene we're
like we're gonna jump in and out a [ __ ]
better to fighting on like the deck of
the ship I don't know what do you guys
think this is a contractual obligation
for John boyega or just the creators of
the new Star Wars like a new like the
new people charge that he has to go woo
in a spacecraft once and move
like to remind us like he's cool why
he's having fun yeah it should be Oscar
Isaac going like and then playing I mean
it would be cool this is a battle I
would
I mean you throw out a really fun idea
it'd be awesome if he jumped on the ship
Mike mid-battle and took over for it
that would kick someone a couple more
also he like we've not seen pictures of
him like flying rebel ships wearing
Imperial or first ordered garb John
boyega is flip flopping like an mf'er in
this movie well let's move the final
shot I want to point out this one of Rey
in the rain holding lightsaber never you
look closely you can kind of see steam
rising off the blade is it like baby
right vaporizes the raindrops I just
love that attention to detail between
this and the snow duel in the force
awakens I just think my super battles
look so much better in precipitation
yeah so yeah we don't really we've seen
this rainy location I kind of have a you
know loose theory it's I'm fully formed
that like this could be part of that
force vision that she had enough in the
force awakens where it was kind of rainy
we saw kylo Ren in the Knights of Ren so
I don't know do you guys think this will
be part of that vision or is this
something literal that we're seeing I'm
gonna go a hard extreme theory here
she's my girl falls New York on the Maid
of the Mist
she's just batting away the Canadian
Horseshoe Falls saying here where
there's something to the similarities
with the the color scheme definitely it
is interesting that she would be able to
yeah yeah well let us know what you
think I actually posted and one other
detail they noticed kind of an
afterthought that I posted on Stardust
so let's um check out me
okay guys new last Jedi trailer what
kind of trail it's a little baby one the
awakes
that came on TV guys I can't get enough
last Jedi footage I love everything and
I see from it notice how it looked like
the Millennium Falcon was bursting out
of the ground uncrate to make me think
that those underground cavern that it
was flying through in the previous
trailer was located on crate very
interesting yeah what happened to you
between shooting that video and now look
way different
that's a Eric after dark and this is
Eric before dark
yeah I'm just saying I like that this is
different version of myself that I just
don't really know and I would rather not
know I know well anyway on Stardust
Tagus and the mad new rock stars that
way you can kind of help us decide which
topics to cover for future episodes but
let's move on to our by-the-numbers
segment and staying on the topic of Star
Wars this number is I guess Star was
related it is
number 80 okay so what do you guys think
the number 80 refers to I have the
answer on this car yeah what's a good
Star Wars 80 1980 the release year of
Empire Strikes Back by that I have no
idea when that movie came out so is
there like an order ad when they decided
to bring the Jedi's back to life after
each word is warmer yeah the number of
people in the last Jedi who are in one
battle see oh the number of product
placements that are gonna be in this
movie for stuff that you can buy later
happen is there like a first coca-cola
yeah yeah all those very interesting
guesses the number 80 refers to 80%
of the new Han Solo movie solo Star Wars
story 80% that bran Howard reshot after
taking over as director that's yeah he
became a 25 year old director again he
was like so excited well this is just a
rumor you know this is just based off of
sources who are working with the show
unconfirmed but if this is true like
antis is bode well is this a good thing
no I think it what it really means is
it's gonna be a Ron Howard movie and
which honestly like maybe at a certain
point it's kind of like seeing your ex
or whatever it's like no make it a clean
break just great I think it's just
entered the budget for it in order to be
able to do all these reshoots if it's
like Star Wars yeah I mean I mean rogue
one had a ton of reshoots as well it
sounds like Tony Gilroy took over for
Gareth Edwards and reshot a ton of
ambition really believe like that this
movie has potential to be great to keep
funneling money and for all the negative
press like when that like when the split
between the original directors happened
to then shoot the basically the entire
movie over again a they no one in the
cast got fired except for Lamar from the
wire because he couldn't come back for
reshoots because of his schedules you
know fire he just there to part ways but
uh so like they must think that this is
a good
somewhere in that script there was a
great movie I mean I hope it also be
like they can't make a bad Star Wars
yeah I think that's there like we we're
still building credibility it's our
biggest play what they can do make a
really bad title reveal because who
didn't think that was gonna be he was
like can we title it again that idea
that they were also really hating Alden
yeah Alden I write like his acting and
there's also a chance that they were
like let's give him another take right
now like he's been now he learned how to
act in this character a little bit for a
year yeah
now let's learn why didn't I get the
role there I got a whole nother tribe
then there'd be huge yeah I mean I'd
still see the movie because it's a Star
Wars actress but ya know it wouldn't it
wouldn't bode well also they were doing
a lot of improv and I've never seen
Alden do any sort of acting like that
great Caesar and he was funny but he was
funny as a straight man that's an
interesting point because we did talk
about how they probably were improvising
a lot more so in fact they definitely
were in Lawrence Kasdan is very anti
improv but he's like one of the best
screen writers of all time so you kind
of like have to listen but it's
frustrating right so thor ragnarok we
saw what happens when it's in hit
inherent in the DNA of the film
structure was improv and the reactions
to things and that's what a thorn what
improv can do to change what the Thor
movies felt like would you guys have
liked that version of a Star Wars movie
yeah I I wouldn't because I think Han
Solo is already a funny character as
scripted in the original Star Wars
movies like I think he is very funny I
mean I talked to a buddy of mine and we
were like Spaceballs it's funny in the
character of Lone Star's funny but Han
Solo is still kind of funnier than loans
yeah who is created as a funny version
of the Han Solo character so I don't
necessarily think totally I I think that
Phil Lord and Chris Miller like fell on
the sword for probably the actors in
this movie and we're like okay we'll
part ways and then they double down on
keeping the cast the same I think that's
probably very admirable but I don't
think a goofy or like even kind of
quirky Star Wars movie more so than it
already is because they're already
inherently can't be and the moments that
are funny add levity to the drop like
you were talking about before they make
it not just straightforward like sci-fi
sadness so I don't think there needs to
be any changing to the tone of these
movies for me Phil Lord and Chris Miller
though do you have a lot of emotional
depth in their in their movies when they
do
and it isn't they had as far as the
moves I've seen that them of them who
I'm stuttering all over the place in
their movies I've never felt like the
comedy has overwhelmed the drama and the
emotional beats they try to do and
walking a fine line yeah they do and I
but it would have been for me who was
just a casual Star Wars fan it would
have been fun to see them attempt this
they shade is it are they almost attend
movies now they're almost there or like
there again yeah it just would have been
fun to see like them just try it like
jezus just give it a shot it's not a
main episode movie that they're doing
it's just a it's an adventure movie it
would have been fun for me I'm still
gonna see this I'm so excited
well we actually have a thought from our
buddy master man hm on Stardust it's
some choice words to say about this
ounce on the movie I guess take it away
master man I'm not looking forward to
solo a stars story we don't need it we
know Han stole we don't need anything
more about him maybe a bit more
Chewbacca but that's it
um the name isn't creative solo solo a
Star Wars story I I don't like it but I
wish we could get somebody else like
obi-wan Kenobi by wow I think we do need
it because Han does not get explored in
the movies he just only reacts yeah but
I want to draw a movie too if that is
okay moving on to our next topic Justice
League okay so the music for this movie
will be composed by the great Danny
Elfman known for his work on Beetlejuice
the Nightmare Before Christmas and The
Simpsons theme song of course the
original 1989 Batman theme now Elfman is
taking over for Hans Zimmer and junkie
junkie XL who did the music for Batman V
Superman Man of Steel in the Dark Knight
movies an elephant said this week that
he would not be using any elements from
Zimmer's score for those movies claiming
that his theme Elfman's theme is really
the only true Batman theme he said that
Zimmer did great things with a
percussion but it wasn't really a theme
so I actually thought whether we do a by
comparison segment here listening to
samples from both
poseurs for these different Batman
themes and kind discussing what we think
Elfman is right or whether there's well
let's actually start with I have it here
queued up the what are you happy that
you made a reference that doesn't exist
to anyone else but us in college okay
[Laughter]
let's start with a sample of Hans Zimmer
and junkie excels Batman theme from
Batman V Superman here we go
okay
great alright great now let's listen
yeah yeah yeah it was just a sample of
it not the full score obviously it's
longer than like 20 or 30 seconds and
let's listen to Danny Elfman's 1989
Batman theme
[Music]
yeah I can get away with without getting
copyright yeah yeah
so Danny Elfman that might not be lying
yeah it's it's not that Hans Zimmer's
composition is bad or remember I mean
it's just not so much trying to be a
theme he's doing a lot of cool things
with like the symphonic elements of it
and glory yeah it's a score and like if
you think for Batman V Superman I think
Zimmer's real agenda with trying to come
up with a new score was that amazing
Wonder Woman theme that he did with Tina
glow and junkie that like his super
iconic yeah we did a separate video on
that but he did do a lot of cool
percussion stuff and I and I really like
the Dark Knight Man of Steel's theme I
think yeah favorite superhero theme cuz
it just feels like you get this kind of
sense of like loneliness but also a
little bit of hope and that I mean the
final trailer for Man of Steel is my
favorite one of my favorite just
trailers in general so and I always will
think about that score to be honest I
kind of totally forgot I had a totally
different idea of what Batman
yeah theme was and I was totally wrong
with it so yeah the Danny Elfman score I
think we all probably had an emotional
response to as soon as we heard it
because that's what a theme does yeah
I've said this before Star Wars has the
best most consistent theme music
everywhere any time you see anything
relating to Princess Leia you hear her
theme or even if she's not in the scene
you've heard her theme and you helped
out the emotions that sort of theme
supposed to do and in Danny Elfman
specifically is great because he knows
how to do macabre like gothic yeah I'm
things and make them accessible to Ana's
a to children yeah so if you think of
like all the like Tim Burton style and
things were these should be
traditionally scary nightmare things yet
for some reason we're like tickled by
going into the nightmare right that's
like something like where he made Batman
it feel a little accessible instead of
like this dark scary thing right I you
know me I'm all about the business side
of things
they call me bottom line back home I
think again this is a smart business
move for Warner Brothers in DC because
everyone sort of Wonder Woman every DC
comic book movie has come out of the
ten years has been this except for Nolan
Batman movies has been panned and been
like this isn't fun we don't like this
but people love Michael Keaton Batman
they love Batman Returns I think like
the second you hear a little Danny
Elfman whimsical Batman theme people are
like parents are gonna get back into it
they've probably shown their kids
Michael Keaton's Batman out of anger and
reaction to Batman vs Superman the big
see kids that's the music I was talking
about I think it's a smart business move
and I also just prefer that theme
because it was the first it's like
Doctor Who fans like the first doctor
that they see like that was the first
Batman theme they still use that theme
constantly in a lot of stuff I I
personally love the Lego Batman games a
lot they didn't use the Lego Batman
theme they used that they use the Danny
Elfman score and when you can play a
Superman the original Superman score
yeah everyone always kind of remembers a
Superman score as well I can't write
weirdly I can never think of it he's
literally going to use this as Batman's
theme any time Batman appears like it's
or is he gonna modify and be inspired by
I think he's gonna modify and be
inspired like he's gonna probably
modulate drag and drop from like iTunes
into the yeah drop box for this mess
obviously we I think we do want him to
update it if he's gonna yeah don't just
burn it in and collect your paycheck but
at the same time I think just for a
second my brain went to what if we had
the original Superman theme when
Superman shows up in Justice League and
the original Batman theme and it kind of
would feel like oh right these are
characters we've been growing up with
for you know all of my 19 years and like
just from and that impact would hit me
so much harder yeah and I did and I
don't know who you mentioned that sorry
but I think they said that they are
gonna be playing with the original
Superman theme in this movie as well and
they're gonna play with it they're gonna
play with it nice in a really fun way so
that makes me really excited so well
let's move on to our next topic
switching over to the MCU again and then
infinity war okay so this week if Amy
were co-director Anthony Russo said in
an interview that when developing the
story for the movie they based
thanassis plot to steal the Infinity
stones on famous heist movies so I
thought it'd be fun if we also think
about our favorite heist movies from
over the years and to a pitch me segment
here pitch me your version of an
infinity war movie mapping over like the
characters and plot points from classic
heist cinema who wants to go first so
well first I have my dumb one because I
love Fast Five oh yeah that's great
yeah but also like to a dumb extent
where like I would love to get like a
sign a muscle car to each Avenger Dennis
has like like a monster truck all of his
sidekicks have little motorcycles my
actual pitch is we map this over
inception cool which in is to me so a
Heisman vote for sure that movies frame
that way yeah all right and what it
really is is the heist itself that it's
being complicated by him obtaining the
stones because now he has the power in
her in that stone and specifically one
of the stones he would get early on is a
reality stone okay so now they they're
like like it's specifically trying to
prevent
okay we got a preventive getting in oh
wait he has a reality one and he starts
bending reality so that literally they
can fight in all the different realms
and they're fighting him like almost the
Doctor Strange kind of places but then
also like you know he could take a
change their forms whatever and they
have to navigate almost a dream world
and go you know to just to understand
like okay well if reality is not
consistent how do we then continue to
follow hey Jason and becomes almost like
a Freddy Krueger yeah yeah that's cool
that's my picture that's pretty cool my
bad idea love the Italian Job and you
put that in there as a suggestion
because I love when those mini coopers
come out they have to like it'd be great
there like Santos and Tony used to work
together but Tony you know screwed him
over so they
and his buddies are coming together to
rip off Stark mansion comes there for
some reason and then you know whatever
bad idea better idea I don't know if I I
was trying to think of I actually just
completely spaced on what the title of
the movie is but I think the way that
this movie could work really well is
just seeing kind of like a mapped like
for plan of like kind of like a battle
strategy I know it's it's a heist movie
but I think the way that they it's maybe
do it in a reverse kind of heist movie
where you're watching it from the cops
point of view in the cops are the
Avenger and then you see how they
strategize almost all over the world are
all over wherever they are working
together to try to stop now yes but
throwing in your element of them
actually getting these stones and
allowing them to alter reality in
different ways and actually like showing
like we've seen pieces of what these
things can do but like really show if
someone knows what they're doing they
can mess up the entire universe what's
really cool about that idea because
because if my gut says like a heist
movie from could the cop perspective is
the boring perspective but not if well
one the town actually the town inside
man is yeah but also that it's that
famous blueprint roll out right yeah
misspelled ornaments and mac and cheese
but there's a really cool angle if you
take it the way of like the cops going
we need to think like the robbers so we
know all the ways that these things are
protected so if we were trying to steal
them here's our plan for how cops would
steal stuff so if the Avengers kind of
have to like let maybe like Rocket
Raccoon or the guardians or something
tell them like look we're experts at
stealing stuff here's how it's gonna go
down yeah and then that's how you get
the fun team-ups of like the Guardians
but also Doctor Strange get the team up
and they go off somewhere and they they
try to stop him but obviously it's not
gonna work because we have another movie
coming after yeah sure first of all
thank you for having me back in to pitch
I know the last pitch was offensive
controversial so heard about this I
guess for me I'm going to take this this
pitch from the point of view of Thanos
assembling a group of shapeshifters
Mephisto Loki and then borrowing through
a deal where we trade a character to Fox
State mystique and then we basically are
living out Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows as the four of them go to find
the Infinity stones Horcruxes if you
will using their shape-shifting
abilities to confuse the people and
owners and possessors of these Infinity
stones to give up the stones ultimately
completing the glove bad guys win always
my preferred way a movie goes anyway
thanks for having me yeah can you
validate my parking no no and there are
no valet is out front we'll know who
gave your car I gave the stand
let me quarterback this car down to
Beverly Hills yes and not my leg and
that's I think my my pitch I guess it's
not really a heist movie but Raiders of
the Lost Ark which is really kind of a
MacGuffin tale yes but the idea of like
getting a plan to go get the thing go
get the treasure and steal it back from
the Nazis as many heist movies are but I
just want like some kind of opening
scene where we see cap or Stark or
someone going into this really cool City
star-lord
getting one of the Infinity stones so
those soulstone whatever it is and then
it just like being lifted out of his
hand by Thanos who just shows it to
swoop in and steal it from them and it
just becomes this back and forth the
whole time you have that Museum there
was a movie that came out a few years
ago as Ben Stiller and people that like
came together to like hi skyscraper on
like a window cleaning Rhea whatever the
equivalent of that is but but Avengers I
want that because it's just like we got
to get back at our boss you know or
office space where they try to stay yeah
that's a good space someone gets
hypnotized and that's
yeah I do really want to see tannaz have
a that convert the classic conversation
with like it's always like the two
leaders so it's the heat scene basically
opportunity narrow have to have that
conversation
yeah the diner yeah and it happens a lot
in a lot of movies on that I just really
do want to see I don't care how they
work that in of vanos talking to and I'm
gonna guess Tony yeah he seems still
kind of leader yeah yeah work at the be
the be interesting cuz my Doctor Strange
would be kind of fun to have that
conversation yeah yeah but also I mean
actually this works pretty well
star-lord could do it too even though
he's not like one of the big leaders and
this he at least understands the who
this person is what he means to
everybody else and what he could do yeah
well let's uh and make sure you guys get
it on this pitch us your versions of
this we want to hear from you guys they
can comment down below tweet at us or
put this on Stardust as well but let's
move on to our next topic involving
Logan now people have been sharing this
week on TV I saw this an excerpt from
early on in the script I was ripped by
screenwriter Scott Frank a note on how
violence should be portrayed in this
movie he wrote now might be a good time
to talk about quote-unquote fights
described in the next 100 100 or so
pages basically if you're on to make for
a hyper choreographed gravity to find
city block destroying CGI F Athan this
ain't your movie he went on to promise
that Logan's health is failing and he's
gonna get his ass kicked and that the
characters in this movie don't just get
hurt they die so if you guys don't mind
I'm just gonna take my soapbox here and
I want to take a moment to quickly rant
about this because I freaking love this
I actually got to see Scott Frank's
speak at the Austin Film Festival last
week and I think anyone telling stories
can learn so much from this guy on the
importance on setting tone right away
there's nothing wrong with boldly
declaring what kind of story you want to
tell and how will be different from
every other story we've seen and Scott
Frank did it so just blunt way and for
me everything I loved about Logan
started with dis declaration in the
script it sums up the whole story the
coarseness of the character the brutal
tragic violence Logan's contempt for the
heartbreak for the way his heartbreak of
the past has been bastardized into this
kid-friendly pop entertainment I think
Logan is one of the
superhero movies ever easily the best of
the year and I hope it went a ton of
awards director James Mangold and actors
Hugh Jackman ippatsu Patrick Stewart
rightfully getting a lot of credit for
their success I just wanted to also
extend a pat on the back
the screenwriter for taking the first
step in this kind of story Hugh Jackman
for getting adamantium claws put in so
they didn't we didn't want to see a NASA
thon there and I mean I always want to
see an effort and we're clear about that
in my final show here you know no one
calls me toffee bottom just a friends
okay there's three people in the world
that can call me Tommy bottom and
they're all here all right we're gonna
move on to our need to know lightning
round where I'm gonna quickly hit all of
you guys with some rapid fire
off-the-cuff questions you have not
heard of these I don't even looked at
these you guys have been kind enough to
tweet them into us
I cannot read online I don't know what
this is it's witchcraft yeah I'm just
gonna quick quickly go through these
okay here we go
Phillip Sam Armstrong wants to know thor
ragnarok or chocolate milk Thor Ragnarok
I'm an adult okay here we go
Tommy do you think Stan Lee is a watcher
no I think he's a pervert well that was
some big-boy science oh I'm kidding cold
sweet old man I think he's a sweet old
man who watches
[Laughter]
he looks but never touches Sam Macedo
wants to know how do you feel about the
upcoming flashpoint movie oh it's a
mistake
there was a mistake there's a there's a
million other stories to tell but if
they want to redo the universe's are
like you know what Ben Affleck he
clearly doesn't want to be here anymore
and a lot of other people are like iffy
on him and they're not know they were
they won't they won't they won't switch
everything like that but I prefer if
they didn't like if you want them to be
like you're spider-man haven't fight the
Rogues because the Rogues are awesome
very true
I didn't hear anything you said just
like Sam and I want I agree with Phillip
who is a better duo I just had this
who's better to eleven man ship with
everyone eleven and hopper or Wolverine
and Laura that's from Natalie a very
good question
this is not a takeaway I love both of
those and I think there's definitely
something there for the I love the the
beautiful relationship that happens
between a man who just wants to protect
a little girl and it's it's like a
fatherly thing that you know they talk a
lot about a mother's instincts and how
she has those feelings in her and turns
out fathers do to some but I'm gonna
give it to the one and Logan just
because that one actually has the
legitimate state of like they're trying
to like kill these people and everyone
here really will die that's Tommy
Carol brown with snow and they all
celebrated Halloween but I've had you
ever participated in el Dia de los
Muertos I have not I'm glad I'm getting
the ones I can really relate to this
year this is my the food ones were agree
I almost once killed Judd Apatow at Dia
de los Muertos festival he ran in front
of my car and I hit the brakes at the
last minute and then he almost yelled at
me before realizing he was in the wrong
and we're sorry but and then I threw a
head shout out my window that's how I
got this job and Sam if Red Hood film
was being produced what actor would you
like to see playing him that's been Paul
for is red hood hood the second Robin a
lot of Batman movies but if they did it
he would be pretty cool I'd say
give him his dude in cynical like other
not long hair man from Supernatural he's
a fine actor I've seen him in other
stuff give him his give him his an age
he'd merely doesn't age like you look
like that since 89 so yeah good for him
all right well thank you to everyone who
tweeted in your lightning round
questions will tweet out next week and
start thinking of your ideas now yeah
god of Lord of yeah you hit it already
okay so uh I knew I knew it all looks
easy let's look at what we got in the
pipeline for videos for videos coming
out in this channel in the next week a
lot of good stuff guys if they aren't
out already take a look at our at our
thor ragnarok post credit scene
breakdown we explained both of them also
a stranger things season to breakdown
guys I found like eighty eighty details
or so and I need four eighty percent of
the new house oh yeah what else we got
oh well you had a breakdown for the
flash episode four out right now but so
five next week it was really fun
elongated man showed up he was very
stretchy yeah we also have like a full
more in-depth breakdown of the whole
movie thor ragnarok clean all the
interesting details like you we already
can tell that we've already go say it
again and make sure our breakdowns
complete yeah we'll also be doing a
breakdown of the Walking Dead episode
two three it's titled monsters thank you
all of you for your positive responses
to the new format we're still figuring
it out but we're happy that we're able
to get them out to you faster hopefully
the same level of quality if not better
quality I feel better about it the same
good stuff yeah and then guys we got a
really interesting feature video that
we've had in the works for a while it's
about some of the darker truths behind
the world of Pixar's Cars again for a
second week in a row I'll be issuing a
heartfelt apology to the Latino
community for dismissing Dia de los
Muertos which I have celebrated before
yeah you can't relate to it I can't
relate to it but last time it was all
food questions this time
I just want to answer a superhero
question I guess you can't always get
what you want but the bottom line is
sometimes you get what you need we have
to pay $250,000 to quote the really
sound saying just put an every week
alright well now comes the time for our
15-second shoutout where each of us has
15 seconds to shout out or plug or
ramble about anything they want already
took my time to talk about Logan so I'll
throw it to you guys sure I use you guys
if you want something to read read Jason
Aaron's Thor run I just read the first
two volumes it's what this movie is it's
what they want it's exactly model it
after this and it's gonna make you cry
it's beautiful it's the only good Thor
story out in like the past like 20 years
man I'm blinking on it on his name do
you remember the name of the robot
lately that's on IndieGoGo Olly Olly
yeah I'll lead the robot he's amazing
you can support him on IndieGoGo he's
the robot assistant that you always
expect from like movies where you get
home from work this isn't their video so
it might not be real but you get home
from work and he goes like hey Phillip
long day it's pretty late yeah he's like
you I'm gonna dim the lights or
something that's like yeah please hey
I'll put on some smooth jazz for you I
want to give a shout-out to Halloween
being over so we can finally start
celebrating Christmas Frank those
Christmas tunes and that Christmas
Thanksgiving turkey yeah
gather your family in the end of
November to begin celebrating halfway to
Christmas time and also isn't that
Batman I mean series coming out of
blu-ray I keep getting messages about
that is that really happening yes please
have that happen and also that's what I
want for Christmas from all of you
bottom line and finally let's return to
the trivia question that we asked
earlier
passes back up I can give it to someone
who didn't write it maybe we have the
answer here just to remind you guys what
the question was
and stranger things - what is the name
of the character played by bodybuilder
Kai Greene and let's review our answers
first Tom you want to read sure
I have Erik's answer in its hammer head
[Laughter]
Philip wrote Bo jacked
vest men ah from your boy Tommy be dad
question mark and then parentheses I
assume he is a father and real well the
answer is funshine okay well what we're
gonna do now is we're gonna quickly run
through some of the other news headlines
that we didn't have time for and Tommy
as the loser of the trivia question you
will have to read these headlines that
are on the prompter here and at the end
of each headline you'll have to make a
joke and cleverly riff on the headline
all won't we heckle you yeah and now
it's time for your favorite segment
other news headlines for the Shazam
movies Zachary Levi announced to play
Shazam and Mark Strong from the Kingsmen
is in talks to play the villain dr.
sivana that's a strong choice MC said
that the Walking Dead should could stay
on TV for decades which by then the
world will actually be over
Oh Disney released the full cast of the
voice actors on the live-action version
of The Lion King including Beyonce is
now that's making lemonade out of Disney
lemon Laurence Fishburne next I'm not
gonna read a Laurence Fishburne hoopla
who will play Bill Foster in the
upcoming Marvel movie ant-man and the
wasp says he is working on an additional
secret project with Marvel it is not a
porno with his pornstar daughter Game of
Thrones production crew for season 8 has
been spotted building its largest set
ever in a warehouse in Belfast hinting
at a massive action sequence that will
be shot indoors also shot indoors
the child of Denarius and Jon Snow what
you wish for dad working progress well
done Tommy although it's amazing okay
well Sam do you want to take the goodbye
is nailing that the chance to speak here
you can go ahead fall oh me Sam bashing
listen to my podcast oh you stupid
answers I'm gonna be talking about Thor
as well but you can follow Erik Voss @ea
Voss you can follow Phil Molina seems so
good at the megaphone Tommy Bechtel and
I wish it was Tommy Potter but it's just
yeah it's bottom line by the way you
know you can set your questions there as
well right yeah yeah and make sure to
hit us up with that reaction our
starters question what do you think was
the funniest joke in throw a ragnerok
tag us at new rock stars so that we can
see it and you know we might feature in
next week's video yeah you made me cry a
little bit of course as always comment
down below tweet us at new rock stars
using a hashtag need to know you can
help us decide what topics cover next
week in just your reactions this video
things you like things you want see more
of like this video share it around
subscribe to new rock stars for all the
deep dives into stuff you love guys
thanks for watching and see you next
week
hi won't you see you ever again but
thank you